the Joe Rogan experience when you had
that situation happen where you know
they were running a bunch of tests on
you they couldn't figure out what was
wrong with you uh-huh
what do you think was going on uh you
know what was funny was that a July
fight yeah when we get ready is in Vegas
right
we flew I had to fly to New York to do
my media day so from Hawaii to New York
twelve hours yeah and then we did 12
hour media and then we went to Vegas I
think I got to Vegas on Thursday and
then you know I just fell out of it and
you're cutting weight at the time - not
really cutting dieting and stuff and
like everybody even the water thing it
was like well I think that's the load of
water fight week even what even with
even before the fight you know we drink
the load of water you know and um a
10-day like a couple days pass and it
just wasn't going away you know and then
what was like how'd you feel I could
talk I could tell you exactly what was
it something was consumed you know and
like right now not that much people know
that I I left my old management
I'm with new management now and you know
my manager now he's like a behavioral
science guy and he's probably like
watching this dream and I was squirming
and while I'm talking about it but we
got we you know like we got stuff going
on and you got a bunch of uh I'm looking
to like work on like with lawyers and
stuff and we plan on suing somebody so
there's what yeah there's a bunch of
stuff that I really can't talk about
that's why he's squirming back there you
know I probably shouldn't be talking
about it too much but that's what it was
something that consumed and like a
supplement uh I don't even know if I can
tell you yeah it'll come out wash for
sure for sure well let me know when is
this all supposed to be settled out we
see you know I just left that to him you
know the one of the great things that I
love with the team is that for me I'm
all about keeping the maintain and
maintaining and I main thing for me is
it's fighting and making sure whoever's
in front of me whatever cupcake it is I
can enjoy that cupcake Wow why they go
do everything else for me and you have
to think about anything else not nothing
it out that's beautiful
that's that's the way to do it you know
if you can have a good team you know
people that train themselves like you
know I'm like he's crazy can't do this
okay like I talked to my I talked to
them
my team like I love the chaos like I
love chaos around me a little bit but
then they make it so simple and it's
great but I kind of stood like to put
myself like I like when things ain't in
order you know like when you come to my
house I love that my room is messy I
people might rip up like you've messy
room or like yeah but you know like I
have somebody come clean it later on but
like I just love the chaos like I like
yeah I'm messy you gotta be a little bit
messy you know just does that keep me
sane if I'm to clean I just I'm like
things going too well things is going
too good
you know like it's just like it's like a
fight way like a fight in you if like if
not if something doesn't go wrong for a
week I'm like nope this [ __ ] ain't
happening I'm gonna screw something up
right now just so we got it do you like
things going perfect don't it feel weird
what everything goes perfect I guess I'm
just different now that is a different
way of looking at things that you'd like
a little bit of care I like a little bit
of chaos me I like I like to know that
there's no like I'm I feel like I'm a
very very very fortunate person and I'd
like to know that things are crazy and
random so I could appreciate my fortune
yeah you know I mean the exact that I'm
lucky you know actually I love that life
is so unpredictable
I mean life is like life is like every
me
MMA is unpredictable or something and
that's why that's why I love it that's
why it's so comparable that's why a lot
of people can kind of compare like they
kind of get it but they don't you know
like fighting is in their DNA like
[Applause]